welcome to those who are watching on
live stream and this is our last meeting
for the calendar year so uh a little bit
luck we'll race our way through that
uh do we have any apologies other than
Barry and Grant doesn't seem to be
any Declaration of Interest
there being done this is great nobody
for the
before
oh sorry I need to move the apologies
saying
thank you
Carrie
and on to the public forum we have
nobody so that's great as well so just
working our way through the uh agenda
and just to give you a heads up the tab
10 that we've got on Egypt which is the
honorary and for Mana family I'm putting
that right till the end of our Open
Session which allows for the two mono
effect reps to withdraw so that we can
discuss their um the honoring for the
year going forward
so just a little bit slightly out of
order but just working our way through
and we've got some major late items as
well so you'll see them come in and then
it's a structured committing on the 6th
of December the 13th of December for the
committee wellbeing committee and we
have the addendum to the government
statement report as well
so we just want to work our way through
and the first item is the minutes of the
bluff community board
somebody like to move those move those
Leslie thank you
thank you
yes I'll just see those from there
didn't move though I'm happy to move
that the major load items yeah thank you
Council
thank you
okay yep sorry remember something we
also have the contractor supply
electricity and which is a document that
needs to be going to public use food
thank you
so we've got that excellent
so just working our way through the uh
um the first issue which is the issue of
the minutes of the bluff community board
inaugural meeting on Monday the 28th of
November
somebody like to speak to that
it's been moved and seconded that we
were receiving yep we're here all right
no discussion on that Leslie in that one
all those a favor all right okay carried
foreign
meeting of council held on the 29th of
November
sorry
yeah thank you you take
this is getting a bit routine
um any discussion around those
being none all those in favor
long-term plan development update which
is on the Tuesday the 20th of December
foreign
thank you
um
so I'll take the report as read uh this
report is the first in a series that
you'll receive as we work towards the
development of the
2024-2034 long-term plan
um
I think the the main point that I'll
just make in opening is that all
elements of the long-term plan remain
draft until the plan is formally adopted
towards the end of June 2024 however it
is
um very useful to as we go through just
confirm elements of the plan so that the
teams working across the various work
streams in developing the plan for you
can progress
um in their their elements whether
that's the financial strategy or the
infrastructure strategy or all the asset
plans that sit behind so this report is
really bringing forward to you the draft
Vision draft Mission strategic
priorities and draft Community outcomes
for your consideration and discussion
and then also a schedule for workshops
for next year which shows those
elements of strategic interest that
Council can work through as it develops
the next long term implant
thanks Sarah and just from my speaker as
we look into some of these workshops
this year I'd like us to continue the
option of still live streaming somewhere
so you'll be aware of that
thank you
any discussion
ring
thank you Mr Mayor
um this is about the continuation of the
ltp mission emission statement which is
who I hope I now
it says to live in good order now
the reason I'm querying this is because
um I don't believe this city has left in
good order what it started with if you
look at the reclaiming of the Estuary
through creating a tip you look at
um even looking at the wahokai river
which is the Estuary where the tip wise
and then you look at the northern banks
of the waihopai river down prestonville
and it's a collection ground graveyard
for vehicles now I don't think we're
leaving this in good order
so I'm just querying it I'm not doubting
that that could be the correct
translation for why hope I but to have
it as a mission statement and really
shouldn't be what we're actually doing
and so far I don't think we are leaving
this place in a good order
as as both
um
um
if I would respond with just with some
advice around a mission statement so
while the vision statement talks about
what an organization is aiming to
achieve kind of in the external
environment so the city in this case for
the invercargill city council the
mission statement speaks very much to
how the organization will work
internally towards achieving that vision
and the values that it will live up to I
think
um there are many experienced governance
people around this table and often what
you want for your vision and mission
statement are um
statements that are aspirational they
are speaking to the values that a group
has
um usually with aspirational statements
there will be some gap between the
reality and where you are aiming to get
towards otherwise
um they wouldn't have that stretch which
is what you are wanting but equally
um it is important that this group
considers that they are realistic and it
is what what you are as a group working
towards so I guess that would be my
advice as an officer
um and just also reflecting as a staff
member that the mission statement has
been used quite extensively by the
executive leadership team and the
management team and it does resonate to
a certain extent with
um us as staff in terms of supporting
you with the vision that you're wanting
to achieve for the city
so just I'll come to you A Minute Tom so
Rhiannon will have an opportunity as we
work through the workshops to address
some of these issues because I mean some
of these have been raised before
that's not to say that they're not
um where we want to go but there'll be
opportunities to look at the
um
confirmly you know the vision and some
of the other statements like that
um what have I sort of better than it
was or whatever
so leave in good order to reiterate
nothing is finalized until you adopt but
equally as we go through is very useful
to the process to actually have the
discussion and confirm that in principle
you as a group are in favor
of the general direction that enables
all the staff then to work and prepare
the other parts so it would be
appropriate to discuss it to some level
now unless you want to defer that to a
certain later point
I mean I think it's field or something
we've had some discussion before and we
didn't resolve it
um so I just thought maybe in our first
Workshop that would be a more ideal
place to give you a studio
The Way Forward potentially
happy to be directed by you mayor but
obviously the meetings now we're
bringing forward everything for
discussion sure
um uh given that workshops are very much
in that Preparatory phase yep I guess
what I'm suggesting is in and I'm hoping
to hearing views from others as well is
that once you start interfering with a
mission statement which is an
overarching thing or your vision you
don't do that lightly because there's
cons implications of doing that
um
to do it right now I think would leave
some counters unprepared about about
what they thought they're going for
so I'm just checking the ability to do
it maybe the first Workshop that we come
into in the new year
there is okay Tom
and I want speaking that subject I
originally intended to
um mayor but I'll just leave it
um it's unusual I think to have a
strategic plan for a council which does
not recognize and need to look after the
safety and well-being of staff
and there's absolutely nothing in this
that does
and I think as we
um
you know the if you look at af5f for
example you know ensuring Council
leadership and delivery is credible and
effective building Community Trust and
engagement I think a separate part of
that and should be itemized separately
it's the fact that we do need to
um to see a look after the safety and
well-being of a staff
yeah
it's completely missing I think at the
moment and I'll come back there in a
minute Tom because we did have some
discussion this morning about that so
there may be a amendment to those things
for rhiannon's perspective Leslie thank
you Mr Mia I was going to speak in
support of waihopo to leave in good
order as a very good aspirational
statement for this Council but I'm
comfortable to defer that to our first
Workshop sure
Darren
I was just wondering if the
the health and well-being of staff was
more an operational matter of not
necessarily part of an annual plan or a
long-term plan
um but maybe to take advice on that
um I'll come back to element ring um
just for your benefit around we had some
considerable discussion that we're just
going to show us this morning around the
issue of health safety and well-being of
staff so um that's why we've got some of
this issue coming forward
uh rangi
yeah like just I I can't believe this is
being deferred to a workshop because we
can't make decisions in the workshop
um but clearly says up there
that it's being moved
seconded to
confirm these things so this is pretty
finite what we're doing here today
I mean sorry I'm a man of logic and and
to me to live in good order please prove
to me given the example instead I've
just given that we are living this place
in good order considering what we did to
the way up by history uh with you know a
landfill and and other things like that
so just sorry I to me it's you know I'd
like to actually have a mission
statement that actually meant something
that I can relate to not not some words
that that that
um you carve on a plaque and sit in
front of you and make you feel good
well two two things like that
um from my perspective I guess one is
that that vision is already in that in
our plan or on the mission statement is
as well I guess you're talking about
whether we can deliver or not some other
another issue again as opposed to is
that the goal we head towards
um and if you wish I'll I'll put it to
the boat the way it is
um but I guess it doesn't give some of
your colleagues a chance to Think
Through whether we have an appetite to
changing our goals and Visions at this
stage or whether we just continue on the
way we are because from my perspective
it's it's not really
the goal itself is whether you can
achieve it's the real issue and you've
you write a number of uh examples where
we're not doing too well in that area
but that doesn't mean we can't improve
yeah right outside down
um I I guess it's important to remember
as a another person of logic that a
mission statement is aspirational so
it's forward-looking it's not looking
back this is the annual plan not the
annual report
and if that shapes our decision making
so if our mission is to make sure the
decisions that we are making are to
leave in good order then I'm quite happy
for it as a mission statement
if we fail in that objective then that's
something that might come back through
an annual report or an election
Tom coming back to your issue
um we've got some
um
some recommendations at the front end
which you could add to if that was your
desire but also in the report you'll
notice on
page
21 I think
we'll get to a minute
a bottom of page three of the report and
20 of board books it talks about the
long-term plan having some strategic
challenges for us
and they and that could well be a place
where we added the health and safety and
well-being of Staff in their
as an alternative
a harshly silence
potentially but that would take some
work from
um Rhiannon to do that as opposed to
um me moving some amendments to the
recommendations Alan
oh did you see me I was just thinking um
an agreement with council department Joe
I sort of read them but the things that
he's referring to
um were a long time before our time and
so we're talking about going forward but
there's nothing to say that we couldn't
at a workshop so it's some way of
perhaps remedying some of those things
that have been done in the past that um
we possibly could but by the way of um
you know like a visual boundary or
something like a tree lines or something
like that I'm not sure you know so that
could be a discussion for a workshop
perhaps sure
he used to be Alex
sorry
what uh councilor Ludlow said
um I think it's really clear that all of
us heard a lot of things during our
campaign period uh and a lot of it was
centered around the city with heart and
restarting the heart and the vibrancy
that we've got in the inner city and
what we're working towards with uh 12 25
so I really don't think that the public
redirect has shifted away from hearing
so I think that's definitely something
that we should be continuing on with but
looking internally
um like councilor Ludlow said let's
retrospect it's not retrospective
um we can't look for at what has
happened and go oh no we haven't done
our job what we can only do is look
forward to the future and see a good
example of what we want our team members
to be aspiring to so I need I really
would like us to to confirm those today
and give them a really good solid steer
as to what we should be aspiring to yep
anymore
uh yeah because language is one of my
things
um
this to leave a good order is an act of
future focused
um remark and I think whilst
acknowledging him and I have been fairly
vocal on this the damage that has been
done in the past
this is not a passive statement this is
an act of looking forward and continuing
thing it goes beyond my lifetime and
to the Future for our mocos so I
um don't
deny the Damage Done but I don't think
that that stops us being active about
our intentions going forward and this is
as others have said aspirational this is
not a finite
thank you
so basically agree with what Alex said
I also think that
that phrase is something that we can use
to reflect on when we're doing things
now how will this help us lead this in
good order so it should be a measure
that we can use when we're discussing
things
foreign
debate I mean I'm actually I like the
explanation that everyone just gave
actually that almost made me not put my
hand up but what I was what I was gonna
say is that you know if councils from
the 1860s had accepted that as the
admission statement then this area would
still be Martian bush
and I I prefer something that's got some
improvement worth in it rather than
simply assuming that you know we're
going to maintain a status quo people I
think elect us to improve their lives
not simply to you know protect what we
already have so I actually like Evelyn's
explanations I wouldn't have a problem
with leaving it but I would just like
somehow to bring in the concept of
improvement
and while you've got your microphone
pulled up Tom would you like to move an
amendment to five to insert G which was
uh some some outcome some draft
strategic priority for
uh health and safety and well-being of
staff
uh
I'm sorry Mr Mia but I agree with the
comment that that is an operationally
focused thing I am grateful to hear the
deputy mayor refer to that and and I
would appreciate it if we could have
that discussion about that being uh
something that we spend more time on at
the council level for the opportunity to
indicate that to all staff but the
long-term plan is a document that the
community looks at for direction on how
the council is going to spend its time
allocate its resources
and I'm not sure that that's the right
place for the health safety and
well-being of the staff who work here
the health safety and well-being of the
community I could Embrace
um but for the staff feels like a very
narrow focus in a bigger strategic
document
and I think that to draw on the deputy
mayor's previous experience
and contrast it with this this is not a
strategic plan for governance to the
organization or for itself it is for the
community
on the future direction for the city and
I think that's the comparison
um that perhaps if we could find a
different place for that conversation of
health safety and well-being I think
that would be a really helpful
constructive conversation between the
this table and the staff
so Tom for your benefit one of those one
of those places might be the chief
executives kpis
I'd appreciate it if it was somewhere
publicly you wish up sorry mayor Clark
um because I think that actually goes to
the very heart of what I understand to
be called psychological safety
uh actually if you are to refer to the
discussion about health and safety then
it starts at this table and it's
interaction with the people who report
to you me and the officers who come and
so I'm really grateful to the deputy
mere for wanting to insert it here I'm
not sure it's the right place but I'd
really like to work with them to find a
place
because I think it is a very helpful
signal to everybody
and I'd like it to be public
for that reason
yeah it would be useful to
debate it you know separately I think
it's absence actually makes a statement
of itself that's a concern
um Mr Mia could I suggest to you that
you take rhiannon's advice that nothing
is confirmed until the ltp is confirmed
I am conscious that uh management has
undertaken this morning to come back to
you with a road map on some matters and
I think that that might be an
opportunity to have a good discussion
about
the deputy means aspirations in this
regard and how to make that reflected in
our documents that provides a really
good signpost to all staff
yep thank you for that Tom all right
would somebody like to move all the
recommendations if that's appropriate
yes
I'll just take it as a giver that you're
doing woman thank you Leslie
any further discussion around those
recommendations in my opinion education
counselor Kraken wanted to say oh sorry
did I
that's okay
um
you're right yeah yep thank you okay
I'll put all those motions all
eight of them uh all those in favor all
right any opposed
thank you
moving on to the community wellbeing
fund and committed in terms of reference
update piano again
so um this paper speaks to a procedural
matter that we're just bringing to
council to request an amendment to the
community wellbeing fund committee terms
of reference this really relates to the
matter of Quorum and ensuring the smooth
functioning of the committee I'll take
the report as written I'm happy to
answer any questions
any questions
getting light in the air you you've worn
them all out happy to move the
recommendations thank you
that's we're all looking at you
counselor Boyle
to move it that's what you're waiting
for and secondly by Leslie thank you and
no further discussion
is none I'll put all three at the same
time
all those a favor oh I carried
Michael Wherever You Are
yeah
so the amendment to the government
statement 20 22-25
foreign
everybody thank you Clark
so as I've said earlier the governance
statement is a living document and needs
to be continually updated this is the
latest round of updates and appoints
people to the various
joint committees
portfolios and organizations who have
requested uh outside
a requested a council representative be
placed in my report we also indicated
the need for three additional members to
be appointed to the center city Heritage
subcommittee uh Council Soper is that
has been appointed as the chair of that
committee once the governance statement
amendment is adopted but there would
need to be three more members of that
uh committee so that councilor Soper has
something to cheer
I believe counselor kit was also going
to bring information back from age
concern uh regarding whether it was one
or two people counselors who are able to
be appointed and I believe he will be
able to speak uh to that and then there
is the addendum which is where the major
late item which has only just come in as
a request from active Southland for a
council representative so if you're
comfortable misdemeer that makes sense
um to me to get it all done
and one appointment round
and with that we will then make the
changes to the governance statement and
it will become live so we need three
three members open above the chair yes
okay Peter did you want to speak to them
yeah I'll put my name forward I was on
that last time
any other volunteers
yeah
thanks Tom
and one more
Ellen excellent good man
we've got those three nominations
Michael
thank you Mr Mayor yep thank you
um so next up would be the comment from
age concern uh councilor kit I think was
going to report back on whether it could
be one or two people appointed yeah yeah
it's only one uh Mr Mia in one person
okay so I think the current appointment
was councilor kid himself but uh
councilor Stewart had indicated an
interest so maybe he has made the
alternate
yeah it seems to be the solution to me
that would be fine well Peter's older
than Barry so
age concerned
thank you Mr succession planning yeah
maybe yeah a bit of succession planning
just in case I think Barry may be on the
pension next year yeah
yeah he's got a way to catch up
six months so you've got those Michael I
have thank you thank you and the last
one is the uh major late item which
which is tab 14 the addendum to the
governance statement report for an
appointee to the active Southland uh
committee
fund uh it was an organization that used
to be managed through this Council but
it has been sent out to a trust and
they've now asked for a representative
yeah there's a conflict here isn't there
Alex is an act of self-interesting
here's my hand typically a search
um I will not
so you're involved at the moment
are you involved at the moment I am a
trustee of active Southland so can you
give us a brief update on what what the
role I can shorten it for you yes and
register an interest yes
um it used to be the active communities
fund that we administered as Michael
said so we just we handed it over to uh
active South and I'm familiar with the
process I'm happy to see one of
counselors actor
yeah
any other suggestions about the
nomination any others
welcome to the folding there you got
that Michael I have got that thank you
Mr Mayor so we've got a
um four recommendations here
on the front end of that and the
nominations that we've now got
so I'll put all four of them together oh
sorry
oh sorry Evelyn I hope you have a
question uh
[Music]
it says edit names of counselors
appointed to museum that would be
redundant I would believe
because that's the um Smeg board
what was the smoke board no no I'm sorry
Mr Mia I'll just clarify that for um
Evelyn that is pointing the portfolio
leads uh and that is uh councilor Scout
I'm sorry we could have clarified that
my apologies for any confusion
thank you
so just on the issue of the portfolio's
model
um yet we're making the appointment
towards um sit
uh but certainly in the health area uh
Lucy has volunteered to cheer that and I
think Rhea you want to be involved as
well so just acknowledging those two
names
um given that um recent meeting I've had
with the other Mayors in Southland they
want a South and wide voice as opposed
to an invercargill voice
so it's probably going to take more than
one person to get around some of these
agencies that are in primary care so
this is very much a primary care voice
as opposed to secondary key so
but there's no other objections or
suggestions happy to put those two names
as well thank you Mr Mayor
and on the issue of housing
um it would be helpful to come back to
that one as well and I think Tom's got
an active role there
and more than one one voice needed or
one person involved in that portfolio do
you think
Miss America
um I think I still need to understand
exactly what's involved in that I mean I
have there's been a number of things and
that we're trading I have been uh uh
I've met a couple of times and we
planted me every month
um I have a meeting with Bobby and greet
South a bit I'm still trying to get a
feeling for you know just exactly what
upward could be I think once I
understand that better then
um I think it would be good to have that
conversation sure
benefit Michael again through the mural
Forum there's a uh I'm a submit to a few
years sorry again if I was looking for
supports at the moment I probably looked
at Leslie so to help and she's nodding
so you know if you need another name
maybe you can
happy to have my name there thank you
and I guess again like well this is
um being generated predominantly out of
State wanting to partner up with some
other organizations
uh going Aura and um but the other issue
is that housing's always been very high
up on the list of issues that southam
needs to resolve a shortage of houses
and we just never seem to get any work
done because it's too complicated so
whether we can
draw some local expertise in and look at
the likes of Hastings it's it's got a
coalition going now between government
local body
um
ewe and some private sector providers to
build about 1500 houses so um we might
get a steer on potentially on that as
well
thank you and at this stage I'll just
sit on the sit well at the moment
because there's some politics around the
transition phase across the new
organization that I'd like to help help
them with thanks Mr may as I've said
earlier this is a living document we can
continue to yeah at name says yeah um
the council desires sure thank you
so I've got um four uh recommendations
here
I'll just put them all in one go
um all those a favor all right Indian
opposed there is none carried
sorry
oh sorry yes
and we've also got the addendum to the
government statement as well so there
are two two recommendations in there
receive the report
and appoint Council Orlando
to be an active person
on the active Community sign committee
this I like to see so I'll put those as
well all those in favor
carried I'm not challenging you to erase
yeah now moving on to tab 11
. before we deal with the issue of the
on-room for Mana funeral ribs
um are you speaking to that
Michael again
gives me again a nice uh report to round
out the council yeah setting your dates
for the coming
yeah 2023 so that you have two options
um
we have option one which is the standard
roll through of our Council meetings
through each month and option two is
something new to try and make a council
meeting slightly more user-friendly for
people and members who have and members
of Staff as well who have family members
who may be at school holidays so that
so for the three term holidays one week
would be kept free of all Council
meetings which would say three times a
year a double up of uh council meeting
so it's generally two committees being
held on the same day so the options are
available to
Council laws but that was something that
staff felt was something that was worth
bringing to you for consideration
and as if I remain happy to answer any
questions
there being any questions happy to
promote the option that includes the
family-friendly care of Warren of errant
children
otherwise we could bring them along to
the meeting and then fix them
just going back torture back to back
would you do still start at three or
start at one or start at two or uh so it
would at this stage it would be I
planned that we start at three but it
would be subject to the likely workload
of the agenda of the agenda if it was
going to be a large meeting then we
would uh take advice and seek to start
the meetings earlier and we generally
have an idea of what's coming in our
agendas in advance so we would plan that
if needed I mean obviously if you do
have a big agenda you do need a sizable
break
and then into the next one rather than I
mean we do five hour risk and Assurance
ones but
the two team to hurt yeah that's that's
not ideal practice
and Michael just from my perspective
um
with the going forward of the workshops
as we lead into
um that middle uh period of the year
when we adopt
um it would be helpful to have a
schedule for the workshops as well yes
that will be that will be forthcoming
once this was the set piece yeah I
understand it was done everything can be
populated from there it will be
populated into all of your calendars
yep uh before certainly but the January
February March runs before the end of
the year so you've got an idea of where
they sit yeah and just reflecting on
what we did at the long term plan A
couple of years ago we had a lot of
workshops and by the time we got to the
end of them and I was about two dozen of
them
um we were struggling to get a quorum
sometimes so that that's a reflection
for those that are currently working as
well have full-time jobs at having a
whole series of them too close together
at the wrong time of the day we don't
get the buying so Mr Mayor I understand
that um
there has been a
list of the workshops provided in the
early report by Rhiannon sure that that
is
something that will be as considered as
part of this as well and it has tried to
space those out more I believe Mrs
Headley needs to say something
I'm sorry
Mia Clark I had to stop
and correct myself
um there's only one appendix to this
report and I'm just wondering uh Mr
Morris has been referring to options but
I'm wondering how he can there's only
the one I've profit in there well I want
to make sure that it is the one that
you've
um Phoenix has been removed yep so the
appendix has uh dropped off because
there was this was a two tab
um my apology spreadsheet
so I am not quite sure where that has
gone
so it's not helpful
so wow
I can speak to it I can't show it so it
was each of the
uh as the April July and September
holidays there was a
I'll bring that up so in April at links
in with uh Easter so it's Community
well-being and finding some projects
that would
thank you
be joined on the 18th
uh
July infrastructure and Community
well-being we're being
joined and in October September sorry it
was infrastructure and Community
well-being again
so what we've got in front of us is not
the alternative with the uh no this is
the classic edition I'm not sure where
the alternator is gone I apologize for
that
um it was there
and now it is not
um Mr Mayor perhaps it could lie on the
table only for perhaps you could just
put it to one space uh side and Mr
Morris could go and get that other
version and you could come back to it as
the last item before well I'm not
particularly uh it's a concept yeah I
think everybody seems to agree that
being used to find the other school
holidays was a good thing so if you can
you can just get a nice colored copy of
each so we can put it up somewhere I
think if that's where we want to go
that's where we want to go send out the
invites so when we move the two motions
and adopt the 2023 meeting schedule
we're adopting the amended one which
gives our uh because of the double up
meetings on those three months to allow
for
I guess people are children to have a
bit of a break
and then give me a clock I would seek
therefore to change my uh recommendation
to be adopt the 2023 School holiday
um School holiday and quote Max uh
meeting schedule sure that gives a clear
indication of the one that you are
adopting
further discussion around that
you're being none I'll put the two
motions in all those a favor
okay
so we now move on to the issue of the um
honorary and for mother funeral so
some other minutes that it's probably
useful to get oh sorry my mistake yes
approved
so one is the minutes of the uh meeting
the infrastructure committee held on the
Tuesday the 6th of December
yeah I'll um be happy to move the minute
to be confirmed and also move
the following recommendations to council
and that is that Council of Soper and
councilor skelt are appointed to the
CCTV stakeholders group and that the
implementation dates for the three
School variable speed zones which are
out of Tara James Hargis senior and
southern girls high schools would be one
February 2023 okay
before I open it up for any discussion
on the recommendations you've got the
counselor could you just give us some
idea on
the likely time frames for the CCTV
I'm not trying to trape you but it just
I get a lot of questions about that well
I'll pass that over to Trudy oh
through you mayor Clark we won't know
until we have established
uh the camera's sites but the original
intent from the consultant was it would
take us 11 months from start which we
started this in November so the time
frame is 11 months from November
last last November
2023 it'll be October 2023 to have
resolved
was that your undertaking ringing look
I'm happy with that I've had casual
conversations with um
uh the consultant when he's been down
here and look the
the background work that goes into
establishing the network that the
cameras will sit on is is quite
complicated considering a lot of the
places where you want to put cameras
don't even don't have power yeah
um there's only data to limited places
so Wi-Fi systems have to be created so
it that backbone is is the hard bit and
then once I guess that's established
then
um a sort of a tendering process for
proposals can then going away yeah yeah
and so yourself and the other two
councilors when you deal with the issue
where the cameras are located uh no look
I'm I'm not on that stakeholder group um
I've only just you know just keep sort
of briefly informed yeah okay um in case
the mayor asks questions
[Laughter]
we do have a range of I guess public
view on where some of these candidates
look well the critical CBD ones will be
done first according to the 250 000
budget yeah
okay thank you
all right any further questions about
the minutes of the infrastructure
committee or the two recommendations to
council
no there's not I'll second them yeah
thank you
um good to have you on every everyone at
the moment Leslie that's really good
um so I'll put those two recommendations
uh
um well that's a favor
and we've got a second one there haven't
we
and the minutes of the meeting of the
committee wellbeing committee
on the Tuesday the 13th of December and
again we've got two recommendations
sitting in there as well
happy to move yeah thank you Darren
thank you Leslie
um
so any discussion around uh what you see
in the minutes and around the two
recommendations to council as well
which is around the master plan
they're being none I'll put the
acceptance of the minutes and the
recommendations
that outline then two and three all this
in favor
carried
all right now on to uh tab 10.
which is the um honorary for the Mana
final reps and I think would be helpful
if we have that discussion without you
being there thank you
okay
uh Mike on the floor is yours
thank you Clark
it says report as promised following on
from the appointment of the manual finra
representatives to set out their level
of honorarium I have undertaken a survey
of uh South island-based councils who
have uh similar sort of roles
um
and as can be seen from the report there
is a wide variance and people's practice
and what what people do you know our
Christchurch City donors not does not
currently have any appointments similar
to the Mana funeral role but they
indicated that if they were to do so
they would be under a policy that they
are developing on outside appointees
remuneration that has not as I
understand it yet gone to council for
them to approve so I don't have any more
information on that
but raise it as a possibility is
something that
council could consider uh should it
choose to going forward from the basis
of what I have uh researched
essentially I've come up with the three
options that you see before you option A
Remains the status quo which was the
honor area paid at the last term
option b is the current renumeration
Authority minimum level for a councilor
at 38 000 which was the
spirit of what was decided at the last
and the last term for these roles and
option C is adopting the DCC or Dunedin
City model of a 750 flat fee but noting
that there would actually need to be
some work on what a meeting was when
considering for the flat fee to be paid
and
um that would need some a bring back to
council to ultimately determine uh so
it's probably enough of a summary for me
I'm very happy to answer any questions
and I'll just leave off with that so
that uh just to thank you for that
report because it was helpful to have us
uh lienzo what other people are doing
um certainly from my Pursuit
um I I prefer option A and that's only
for the reasoning that I think there
needs to be some differential between
manafinoa which is not and that they're
only different to anybody else that
might be represented on their committees
um and the level of work that's done by
councilors at the base rate so if I
consider our current people
that are on there and I consider uh
Leslie's role on on Council and all the
other committees who she's put a hand up
there's a significant difference between
those two um
working effort wise I think that's not
to belittle what monofino would bring to
the table but I think there's that
differential would be helpful so I'll
just open that up and allow people as
they work their way around Darren thank
you thanks mayor Clark
um I'd be supporting option b option b
actually still has a differentiation
between
standard counselor and I think there's
another 4 000 or so um up to what is it
42 a little bit over 42 yeah yeah
um that recognizes the fact that we as
councilors also have those other ad hoc
bodies that that we're on
um the uh remuneration pool for us was
increased this year and and I think it's
just in keeping with that sense that the
lower end
um is also an increase for the money
funeral representative sure I think it's
probably helpful I just work my way
around the room I think as opposed to I
think the hands up because good to hear
what everybody feels under metallics
what's your view clerk um I too will be
supporting option b I think it's um
reflective of the amount of effort that
um our appointees have to to put in and
although they may not be appointed to
other ad hoc uh committees they have the
obligation to be Consulting with your
own monofino representatives in their
own communities and bringing board
um good information uh so that we have
you know we're well equipped and we're
well equipped as well so or they
although they're not may not be on our
official committees I know and we can
guarantee that they'll be soliciting
with their own as well okay
and just just for the point of
clarification B refers to 38 642 which
is the I understand Michael the current
Baseline that came from the authority
it's a minimum payable yeah but just
being mindful that when we're
considering this that we have increased
our Baseline to just a fraction over
forty two thousand so and that doesn't
mean we can't still be at 38 per month
so yep Leslie thank you Mia Clarke I'm
also a strong supporter of option b not
only do I think it's very much in the
spirit of the original decision of
inviting manafinoa to be part of this
Council but I also believe that it
reflects the work we're asking those
representatives to do I do agree with
the comment that that role will probably
grow in a very short time but we know
already that there are requirements on
those representatives to liaise with
their own communities and bet liaison
will only wide and I believe with
manafinoa as well I'm very comfortable
that option b reflects what we see it in
the spirit of bringing these
Representatives into our body and
acknowledging that they were an
important part of the future functioning
of this Council sure thank you for that
Nigel a big for all the reasons
previously stated yeah okay trash
um I'd go with option a
um I looked at the research that Michael
did and it seems that they're currently
receiving
um quite a payment that's more than in
other places so I would um go to option
A
yep ringy
um but can I start with a question sure
absolutely clarification
um are these positions
um do they do they put forward the voice
the representative voice of their
particular Rooney or is it their
individual price voice they bring
that's my question that is it what are
the positions for are they two
individual people or are they each of
our and why I hope I
the reason I ask that is that previously
in a item that was about rangatahi at
Splash Palace
um
we had one of the representatives say
that they they didn't want the rangatahi
there because of the noise and and you
know the congestion they cause and I'm
just wondering is that I don't think
that would be the view
of that particular
you know considering what we're trying
to do with rangitahi so I'm just
wondering
and this will affect the way I
think about the remuneration is it as
their position can anyone advise us on
that yeah I can probably help with that
I've had some discussion with uh ewe
leadership
um they represent the two Rooney
separately
um
while some may have a view that do they
represent
monofinoa in those areas or is it a
personal view well you could you could
throw the same question at every Council
around this table are you giving a
personal view or are you are you
reflecting The Wider community and the
challenge for us is how do we know what
the community wants on some issues so I
guess
um I guess just to interrupt you there
sure we were elected as individuals and
they know individually where we stand
you know some of us you know without
yeah I don't appreciate that you know
you get what you pay for and the other
issue I guess is the issue that when we
first adopted these two positions the
idea was that they would also consult
with the mother Walker which is the
non-monafenwa
hearing of our community
um and unfortunately they're the
majority and I don't think that works
all that well but that's something we
need
to promote with the EB leadership who
are coming to meet us tomorrow
okay
now and so may I clock my response would
have been it is as you've just said it's
both uh they speak for the runaka that
is there well that's what they are
appointed to do but as with all people
they also have personal views that will
from time to time be [ __ ] and it's not
inappropriate
um in a forest such as this
but they have accountable accountability
back to the runaka for what they say and
don't yeah
again okay so option action thank you
Tom
I I think who someone finds the weight
of this table whether it be by
appointment or by election it's pretty
much irrelevant to this discussion
anyway
um I think with Mars is the the work of
the role and the team commitment
I think in terms of what could the basic
rule
um this certainly have accountability
for you know a talker to their community
and you know understood but so do we
actually we have we have that
accountability too I think the
difference
for me as team commitment and when I
look at the previous document the
governance statement each Year's as
counselors set on you know typically cf4
committee subcommittees Community groups
as well as the the main committees and
and councils so there is a difference in
team commitment
um so I think it is appropriate to think
about a Delta between the earnings of a
counselor and the earnings of a
um earnings of a representative for that
reason
um I I could easily be brought to
support either a or b
um I have you know such as Maria Tony
think in terms of D I always think it
was there's two things I think about in
terms of of a d one is that we take e
and apply RPI to it
um so that
um because otherwise it's actually a
decrease
and remuneration
um so we may whether that Pi is you know
six or seven percent or something like
that we could apply that to it
um and not with that is the logic behind
that another approach might be that we
take the 42 000 that members have paid
uh and you know say take 90 percent of
that for example I actually both of
those option D's I've just mentioned
um last year's plus RPI or the 42 000
times 90 both end up pretty much the
same they end up 37 000 something so I I
think that's uh you know maybe rather
than just choosing a number you know
that that has that has maybe a a logical
way arriving at a number I I would say
though
um and I guess I said it before that if
we if we agree exactly the same
remuneration as last trainium then that
actually represents a decrease
so I don't think that would be
appropriate
so given up we don't have a d at the
stage are you saying B
pardon well we don't have a d but no I
could easily per B up but probably
between if I was forced to choose
between the two because I think it ought
to be higher than e to represent
inflation I would choose B
right Mr Mayma I asked us um the
question and uh
when we
spoke about how the Manawa can receive
the on an erum there was discussion that
this could be and would be discussed
about the runanga coming to that party
as well
um and looking at some type of payment
that the council not under the council
she pays but also Rooney so that we had
that I guess when I'll say it that
accountability
um from our Representatives they were
coming forward with the voices and the
direction of each of the arunanga
um a comment that I'd like to make too
is that yes
um many uh matter what I do want to be
involved but unfortunately they're not
yet here at this table how they could
change in the future I'm unsure
completely of that
um but has there been Michael any
research
I'm looking at the option of that
payment to be split by rununga and
Council so that
everyone
is equal in that I speak to a degree
yeah so it was it has been looked at and
it is just it's discounted it's not
something that from what I understand
don't know who leadership are interested
in doing uh I think the only exception
ever to that was what happened at
environment Canterbury and that has now
changed with the permanent deployment of
two an Ito representatives to ecan
through legislative change and they are
now treated as councilors and enumerated
according to their enumeration Authority
so my understanding of ecan before the
legislation was moved is that there was
a 50 50 split between
um
EK which is environment Canterbury which
is a regional Authority and naito prior
to the legislation changes yes and that
came about largely as a consequence
after ekan's elected members were
removed and Commissioners were appointed
uh the crown at that time appointed
naitahu Commissioners so that they had a
voice to be represented at that time and
no when of course elections returned and
later who wished to continue that
voice and that has developed from there
to the amendment act you saw that was
enacted last year
please my house clear a little bit of
the fog
um when I was I'm reading through the
report and wondering about that that
lever that could be an option
um
I do hear what Tom is saying about the
options and eating in the RPI
um because yes option A would be
actually a slightly less
um on anarium than what they're
receiving now but I want to point out
just as equally that as a new counselor
the workload
um is quite substantial depending on
your interest in being here for the
people of your city
um and uh
whilst I can support well and truly the
intentions of having monofinoa here
um
I do think that there is two distinctive
ways in which we carry out our roles
one's legislative one's going that way I
think
um down the way but not currently there
um so
we don't have an option D but I wish
there was
um I I wish that Tom would eat as as a
are we capable of moving emotion to add
an option
um look I think it's best to works with
option A and B at this stage because I
will open it up once we've had the
discussion about whether we should have
an option that says option A with with a
cost of living adjustment to it which
would move it up and whatever the cost
of living is at the moment something
probably close to seven percent
um
and whether it changes your thinking
going forward okay
I also noted just for a bit of clarity
in my report mayor Clark that I had
indicated that it was possible to
request a report back
um to address this part way through the
term to allow for the cost of living
Rises to ensure that relatively was
maintained it could be done now through
a motion suggested by uh councilors Bond
or Campbell but it can also be done as a
bring up at some stage in the next year
sure so but I'll come back there in a
minute when I I've got what people do so
which way are you leaning at the stage
for you
and it was just purely on ARB what
should I okay I will open up the other
option
just to make sure that where they're
lames with people
me
um well
I uh
I think option A and why I think
obviously one of the reasons there's
many many reasons but um one of them is
a is a different bits and pieces that
counselors do I suppose to the monofino
Reps and now the reason is that um
I believe that uh everybody believes
that everybody has a chance to vote in
local body elections
and then uh so the Azure point is an
extra thing and a burden it causes a
burden to wear right Powers sure if it
was split uh halfway between uh running
is in the uh
Council
um I'll probably say give another
differently perhaps but uh at the stage
itself sorry okay Peter yeah thank you
Mr Mia
option C is not really an option because
uh there's no dollar figure mentioned
like 750 dollars per meeting like could
there be two meetings per month
there would be 18 000 per year or we're
talking more or less or is it going to
be closer to 30 or what that same
counselor okay there are in the report
there are some scenarios around what
that could look like
um as a three meeting because there's
the two committee meetings that are
manafino or appointed to a plus the
council meeting they're entitled to
attend uh there was a figure
um
three 27 27 000. thank you council is
over and uh 36 000 uh if it was the four
meetings each year as they man I feel
are entitled to attend risk and
assurance and finance and projects so
that's why I had indicated that there
would actually need to be some more work
on what is a meeting uh so that we had
an actual indication of what manafina
were attending because that as mayor
Clark has just mentioned the uh
long-term plan workshops are also coming
that we would expect them to be a part
of that was going to be on top of
potentially Council meetings not every
Workshop can fit into a council meeting
day so that would there would need to be
some significant work to agree what is a
meeting and that's the only reason there
isn't a finite figure sitting there but
this is it on a rough
rule of thumb three meetings twenty
seven thousand and four meetings 36 000
and Bluff community board for um
hernia coat is on top of that again
so I guess uh thank you Mr me I've got
another couple of comments to make uh I
believe that we should have a present of
a manner for anywhere reps here but
and not as close to the
earnings that the elected members have
got because they haven't had to face up
to the public they're they're appointed
here
you know I believe that anyone around
the table here that should go to
anywhere near the councilor's rate of
pay
should should not even get half that
amount or around about that figure but a
question is
um do they just represent
the invercargill city and Bluff area yes
so that's where the funding comes from
to pay them at the stage
correct okay at a you during the last
council meeting we had a debate on three
Waters
and one of the monofanoa Reps was more
concerned about the people that were
living in Wario nightcapes in our high
area more concerned about them
then our local people about the three
Waters so that is not representing the
invercargill invercargill citizens or
rate payers so I can talk to that point
Peter thank you certainly at the
beginning of the year when I appointed
the cheers and particularly rang in down
here either
cheers of the two big committees
um I made it clear that
um that's not an issue for Evelyn to
worry about it's an issue for us as
cheers to manage that if any member
starts to stray off into an area which
is a historical one or something that's
not relevant to the city that has cheers
we needed we need to pull back that
discussion so it doesn't continue to go
on and so um
I'm hoping that what I've seen in the
more the last couple of months is we
haven't gone off into the the comments
you had were from a previous term
okay so this stage my quick count is six
five in favor of them staying where they
are and but before a fish
um I'd certainly like to go back to the
ones that are in the B category
um and just say to yourself would you
feel more comfortable I'm not trying to
manipulate this because we'll end up
having a a sharp hand anyway without
necessarily recording who goes Which Way
um just so we're clear would it be
better for those that have opted for B
if we had a
um cost of living adjustment to that
initial figure of 34
667.
I've done the calculation sure 37 091
dollars that would be that's CPA at
seven percent which is what it was last
month yep oh can you repeat that figure
please thirty seven thousand three seven
zero nine one yeah
so this pushes between a and b a little
bit Yeah so again I know this is a bit
of a drawn out process but we want to
get it right
yeah
um I don't want to go around the table
again but if anybody's feeling
uncomfortable about that scenario Now's
the Time to be saying it and I will go
around the table if it is yep Alex
um thank you councilor Clark um I just
really am going to put in another patch
for option b rather than option D
um The Bermuda Russian Authority does an
extensive amount of work and determining
what the base lock base amount of
remuneration should be for the base
level of work that any counselor puts in
our monofinoa reaps do that Mahi at the
very Bay at the base level they
definitely come up to that another thing
we need to remember is that we are
inviting participation from monofinoa
and a colonial framework to begin to
take steps towards fulfilling
tea
gradually paying them substantially less
for a similar workload to our base level
is not in good faith
I understand the meat trick of trying to
Aid adjustment to what they were paid
last year but that's not how we were
measured we were measured by the
remuneration Authority and the
remunerational authority has determined
that for us I think that we should
listen to the remuneration Authority and
let them and their research dictate what
that base level
should be
and just on um councilor kit they do
certainly face up to the public as well
um there's been multiple articles where
they get dragged through the mud for
having their own um personal views and
stating their personal views at the
table as well
um so I don't I don't think that they're
free of that public accountability
um
that's your opinion yep so I don't want
the comments about other people's
opinions we'll just let them Express
Leslie
thank you Mr Mia I'm going to agree with
everything that Alex has said and try
not to repeat it but I am going to say
something that I said at the original
debate
um
natako roro
[Music]
with your food basket and my food basket
the people will thrive
we invited manafinoa to this table table
as part of the partnership under
titiriti or waitangi the founding
document and Covenant that this country
is based on WE invited those people to
be at the table
as equal partners
because it was important to us and in
fact the entire country that that was
shown that partnership approach was
shown and we could make a small
contribution to that
I'm
there for
somewhat horrified to be having this
discussion and I'll just emphasize what
councilor Cricket has said very
carefully
the remuneration Authority made some
very deep Research into the base
responsibilities for which they they
came to a base salary
we discussed fully when we invited
monofino rips to this table
the base salary and the fact that we
were
ready to agree that we were inviting
people with the expectation that they
were doing what amounted to the the base
work
I am not comfortable with saying that we
will take the old base that has been
replaced by the remuneration Authority
and find some device to add or subtract
from it
to arrive at a figure that is somewhere
in the vicinity of closer to the base
remuneration Authority for me it is
quite simple we invited a partnership we
said we would partake in that
partnership
and I would like to see us agree to that
so I I also very strongly make the case
again that option b is what I am
comfortable with and believe is what
this Council should be committed to
thank you all right Michael just to
clarify a couple of things
That Base rate of 34 000 last year was
not what councils will pay was it just
as this year we've got 38 as a baseline
or 38 and 642 as a baseline but we've
been able to
um
move around the figures within the
overall fund itself to now create a one
that's slightly over 42 so even if we
went to option b we are still going to
be at least four thousand dollars
short of what a council says so I guess
in some ways for me it's when we say we
want equality we've never had equality
and even if we went to option b we still
wouldn't have a quality am I right
assuming that
that's a Hard One to answer uh Mia Clark
but the answer is is yes because that
was the minimum that was set by the
remuneration Authority
Council was always and has always been
able to determine uh that minimum
allowable
um there that's decided to pay
councilors who don't have any other
duties
um and each time that has been higher
than the minimum set by the authority
and just as an example of that I know in
Dunedin City
they had two councilors on the minimum
allowable for their uh Council and
propose that to their enumeration
Authority and the authority rejected it
and said that's not appropriate it's too
low which is interesting given that the
authority itself set the minimum
allowable level but it's just an example
of the authority ultimately is the
decider of that bit Council levels
Council laws get to determine
their own minimum base rate because it
was my recollection last time
that when I was a counselor I was on
about 38 or just a little bit shy of
that even though the yes minimum was
actually set at 34 and a half yeah so
the minimum last time was 34 and the
council determined that the minimum pay
to a councilor without any other duties
was about 38 000 I'm sure
Alex
just to expand on that your worship
you're quite right and I see um you I'm
following your logic and that even if we
do decide for option b there's still a
substantial difference between that and
whatever we're considering considering a
base middle counselor rate but then that
recognizes uh what um councilor Bond had
said uh in the workload of incoming
counselors and the others and like like
yourself said about
um councilor Soper and you know many of
us opting for other additional
committees so there is a differentiation
there I acknowledge that but it is
at the level that the remuneration
Authority has deemed appropriate rather
than a figure that we've decided to Wing
up
things well and correct me if I'm wrong
Michael but I from what I understand is
the remuneration Authority doesn't sit
motherf animal type
um on her earrings yeah correct um our
our issue is that when we appointed them
in the last term and we have pointed
them to the base rate of
what do you mean National Authority said
was about right we didn't appoint them
to the rate that we are actually on
ourselves correct
Jimmy Rainey oh sorry Tricia was
performing
okay look just I just want to go back
shake the truck up and ask how did we
what did we originally offer the
remuneration oh sorry the amount of
remuneration for a start so we offer
that minimum base rate great originally
or did we offer something lower and it
was turned out well we had a range of
options last time now and I think from
my memory and Michael might clarify if
we didn't we got to quite a team's
meeting because we had minor funeral
present during that discussion which
wasn't helpful and
they clearly thought they wouldn't be
paid less because we had quite a ranks
last time if you can remember there was
a figure of 100 of the base rate uh 75
and 50
um the 50 potency with a naitai top up
and and we end up landing on 100 which
meant 100 to 34.5 000.
so okay and and knowing that then I
think whatever what the remuneration
Authority is set but this Council has
absolutely nothing to do with it
whatsoever we've conveniently chosen
that that figure okay but I don't
believe the rim Authority with its full
of money that it gives counsel to to
divvy up because this money comes out of
rates effectively as straight up costs
so look I I could live with a
um you know a cost uh cost of living
increased
35 but that that rate has nothing to do
with the rim Authority you're
recognizing anything sorry I I'm I'm
very happy with option A need to yeah
and I accept that but you just need to
be clear that on the 34 667 that was the
base rate from The Authority for the
last term and we agreed to pay that we
didn't pluck that out of there it was we
I can quite recall that we had 50 75 and
100 on the table and we decided 100 so
it wasn't 100 of a just some mystical
number it was 100 of the minimum rate to
be paid
under the authority great so if we don't
pay that this time and keep it on that
we're sort of deviating away from that
expectation and I'm quite happy with
that but I'll just just want people to
be be quite clear on that
all right any further discussion yeah
trash I think
um what we did with air and coming to a
decision about our funding was a very
good system there was a process that we
did and that's how we'd you know that's
how we decided on what was going to
happen and I think what's um councilor
Clint Campbell is suggesting is probably
a similar way for this so that instead
of us having to have discussions all the
time there's a process that we go
through that we add the cost
um you know whatever terms that's even
perceived and
based on the money that they're
currently getting and I don't know
whether my voters there but
I definitely think that that's a
reasonable way for us to look at it yeah
so so working through this process and I
I just want to talk now to the a option
people so you can refresh my memory who
they are I'll know some of them uh are
you open to a CPI adjustment of seven
percent
rainy yeah Tom
yeah
I personally I think that that's fair I
think well we
um the rules and Duties are very similar
and as I said before I don't think makes
any difference how they arrive at this
table Yeah but the work load is clearly
different and and with apologies to
councilor Soper for choosing her I just
have to note something first case let's
open it is not 11 11 additional
committees trusts and joint committees
11. which we do not ask manafina to
participate in so there is a significant
difference in workload so I I think on
that basis I don't have a problem with
it being a differential between the two
sure
oh yeah
with your eye Your Eyes Only I was I was
I um a index of seven percent sure
yeah I'll die yep
thank you Mr Mia I'm not happy with
option A
and I'm not happy with option b because
as I said earlier they're far far too
close to what elected members get far
far too close
but in saying that
I'm sure I was not elected here to sit
on the fence
I've got to make a decision
I'll reluctantly go for option A even
though I'm still not in favor of option
A but I'll go for option A well uh let
me make comment to that I respect
somebody that that speaks out of
alignment with other people and I think
it's okay for you to vote the other way
if you know the numbers are on the table
now if you vote away from option A I
think it's too high we'll we'll get to
five in favor of option A with a CPI and
five and option b and I'll end up with a
casting bait
and I'm happy to take that it gives you
the right to say that you're not happy
with option A I'm not happy with option
A or B yeah but I'll look so I'll go for
option A because it's the cheaper option
what I'm suggesting to you if you don't
want to focus on that if you want to
abstain because you're not happy with
either
then that won't interfere with the
result at the end of the day but it
gives you the option to say what you
want to say
so that's a choice I'm giving you
thank you
what does that mean
I can't write down thank you
you've got the option of a or or nothing
I guess you've got your numbers for
option are you telling me I do have okay
I will not be voting okay
Darren you're sorry I think the council
is confused are we talking Ira plus yes
he doesn't want either right so that
that leaves us with the options of a
plus the CPI or B and by my assessment
they're about fifteen hundred dollars
apart
um and that looks to me is that'll be a
five five split I only got four for a b
I've got five
I want to run around the table again
one two three four bees in a row
s
have I got this wrong
I think that
sure okay okay it's appropriate that
you've discussed it it's appropriate
that there's a motion to which sure came
yeah just debate yep
okay well not just a question of clarity
on that sure um increase of the CPI
um look the councils and this will be
through the mere tour termite is um
the the increase for the base rate for
council's remuneration does not increase
every year in fact it can go for a few
years without increases is that correct
the authority makes it such a
determination and it may determine to
have no increase for a council at any
given time it is unusual for there to be
no increase
each year
The Authority looks at it each year
and generally there isn't an
it looks at the pool yeah for the start
of each term right right they're just
realizing the the last increase for this
Council was quite a significant
most councils had a decent is that right
most councils had an increase okay so it
wasn't just a catch up from lack of
right so just to make it clear on what
you're alluding to rangi which is if we
start building in a Sim CPI does it
continue to go on each year if we build
it in it would be my recommendation that
option A just has a dollar figure
and we know it includes a CPI adjustment
but if you start putting in CPI then it
becomes an expectation every year that
you get a CPI adjustment given that this
is a one-off this is not what's
determined by the uh Authority because
it could leave the door open for another
funeral to say we we want a CPI
adjustment every year regardless of
whether the councils get one or not
can see that the day isn't it
just to make a point and I think he
wanted to ask is Sarah an adjustment by
the remuneration Authority annually
Michael
uh just a matter of Correction the CPI
is running at 7.2 percent as it
currently stands just when you're
discussing it
so the remuneration Authority does issue
determinations each year thank you
um sometimes there's a movement
sometimes sometimes there's not but I
don't think there has been any movement
for the last couple of years until the
trainium elections thank you I I took it
sort of through your chair into Michael
I actually calculate I looked at it up
until the day the election
for the previous 12 months I presume
you've looked at a [ __ ]
pre you know so if it was back dated and
you know if it was back dated to the
election then seven percent would
probably I think would be the
appropriate amount because that is the
CPI as of that date whether it's seven
or seven point two I think you would
need to back that to the 1st of November
the inaugural meeting when manafino were
reappointed just for a matter of
procedural correctness in it
it's there
I'm noticing that there isn't currently
an option D which is the status quo plus
the CPI
um we're waiting for someone to move
something yep so I'll move to just to
bring this to here that option A
um removes the status quo and just
reflects
um
thirty seven thousand and ninety one
dollars which is a seven percent CPR on
top of that figure but doesn't record
that it's CPI just the flat rate
because if you do put the wording in
there'll be an expectation ongoing
second there so you can let trash 7091
so we
only want and just take out the original
figure
oh yeah
in remote State okay well any final
discussion on this before we put that
motion
okay I'll put the motion and that we
adopt
um option A if I have a second for that
which is Trish
um and helpful to show a show of hands
and that's not for recording purposes
because there is some degree at risk
with this and just so I make sure I've
got the the numbers right and I'll take
PTU as an abstainer if that's what you
wish as well so just all those in favor
of option A that's now being amended
thank you so that's carried and taking
Peter as an abstainer
all right thank you very much for that
Mr mirror I'd like my vote recorded
against please certainly yeah
Darren as well Alex
yep he was just a three wasn't me
three opposed yep that's fine
so that's us done on the on the um open
part of the agenda
win yet
we now need to move into publicly
um exclude thank you Darren and Leslie
this is where you nod your head Leslie
yeah I think thank you so we just work
through the uh
through that part of the agenda thank
you Logan